ALISTAIR POTT: Well,
like Mekka said,
thanks very much for coming
to the hangover shifters.
This has been dubbed by my team.
We really appreciate
it, and welcome.
So we're going to be
talking [AUDIO OUT] We're
going to be talking
about making money,
or how to make money
on Google Play.
So Google Play is this
gigantic digital marketplace.
Android has way over a billion
users, soon to be two billion--
even more users.
And Google Play is how those
users get software and content.
So we actually-- we view
that as a very, very
important responsibility.
And the way that we
make that possible is we
built this marketplace platform.
So that's how we get
all this to those users.
And for marketplace,
you need transactions.
And that's what
we three work on.
So we make the Google Play
Commerce platform happen.
So basically, you can think of
our job is to make developers
like yourselves successful.
We want everyone
to be successful
selling content and
software on Google Play.
So I'm Alistair Pott.
I lead product for the Google
Play Commerce platform.
I've been a retail
guy all my life.
I started off in South
Africa, where I grew up.
More recently, at
Zappos.com, and at Amazon.
And I've been at Google
for like three years now,
and I absolutely love it.
I'll let the other two
introduce themselves.
MEKKA OKEREKE: Hi, everyone.
My name is Mekka, and I'm
the Engineering Leader
for Google Play commerce.
I've been at Google
about three years,
and before that I was at Amazon
also-- big retail commerce
nerd.
There I built a little thing
called the Amazon app store.
And before that I
was an app developer.
I had a company that built
a lot of mobile apps.
Probably the one that
you've heard of most,
is-- [? Zagat ?] to go.
So--
TAMZIN TAYLOR: Hi, everyone.
My name is Tamzin Taylor, and
I'm the Partner Development
Manager at Google Play.
My background is
all mobile content.
I've been building and making
money out of mobile products
for about 15 years.
ALISTAIR POTT: Cool,
thanks very much.
So the Commerce platform, one
of our biggest strategic pillars
is Reach.
We have this vision that
every single person on Earth
should be able to transact
easily on Google Play.
Basically, how do we bring this
gigantic, gigantic audience
or market to you,
the app developers.
We have a big team
working on this.
This team wakes up
every single morning,
they're out there right
now thinking about how
we can achieve this vision.
One of the best
things that we can do
is support local
forms of payment.
So we've got this
gigantic marketplace, way
over 140 countries, way over
a billion users potentially,
and the fact of
the matter is many
of them just don't have
access to credit cards.
So credit card support is great.
But it's just
nowhere near enough.
And so local forms of payment
is a huge deal for us.
And we have a large team working
on this all around the world.
Very regularly we are
launching new forms
of payment in countries.
So what is an example there?
So direct carrier billing
is a great example of that.
We call it DCB.
Giving users the ability
to make purchases in apps,
to buy those [? games ?] and
put it onto your carrier bill
is a huge, huge deal for us.
So the chart on
the right there is
showing what happened when
we launched direct carrier
billing in Indonesia.
We didn't even have all
the carriers in Indonesia
at that time.
But you can see buyer
growth was great,
we were always growing
our buyer base.
But as soon as we launched a
local form of payment other
than cards in a country
where credit cards are not
widely used, growth went up 4x.
And this is something that we
see over and over and over.
Recently in Turkey,
Saudi Arabia,
all sorts of countries where
credit card penetration is low,
launching direct carrier
billing and other local forms
is a huge deal for the business.
I always think this
and I recommend
speak to your BD partner.
If there's a country that
you really care about,
like if you're
massive in Indonesia,
make sure that
you know when this
happens so you
can take advantage
of those spikes in buyer growth.
So this DCB is important to us.
So I'm actually really,
really proud to say
that we fairly recently
crossed over the 100 carrier
partnerships barrier.
And we actually just
carried right on going,
105 carrier partnerships around
the world in 41 countries.
And unbelievably, that
means more than 600
million-- actually quite a
lot more than 600 million
active devices have access
to direct carrier billing.
So it's like a one tap or a few
tap to set up a form of payment
on Google Play.
This is a huge job.
We have a big team working with
carriers, setting up the deals,
maintaining the deals,
working around the world.
But as you can see from
the previous slide,
this is totally worth it.
So the buyer of each team
is always out there adding
more direct carrier billing.
Another great form of payment
is the Play gift cards business.
So I always talk to
people about gift cards,
it's like a magical
form of payment
because it gives the
users the ability
to use whatever form of payment
they like, the big one is cash.
So every single day,
every single moment
we have people walking into
like a 7-Eleven in Tokyo
or a corner store in
Indonesia, handing over cash
and getting Play balance
back and then using
that in your apps.
It's a huge deal for us.
It's also a huge operation.
There's a physical
retail, there's
a lot of regulation
around this stuff.
We've got a big gift cards
team, and they do great work.
Over 500,000-- actually
way over 500,000 locations
that have Play gift
cards available to them.
So almost anywhere in Brazil you
can walk around and get a Play
gift card if you want.
So we constantly are
working to bring more reach.
We actually have a big team
that works on this stuff.
They're working with banks,
they're working with carriers,
they are working with specific
local forms of payment
in all sorts of countries.
It's a huge job, but we
take it extremely seriously.
And we've got some
really cool local forms
of payment coming in
India, in the Netherlands,
in Germany, and Korea, and in
other places in the future.
This is something that we care
deeply about, we invest deeply.
This is how we can bring
reach to yourselves
and the rest of the developers.
And then lastly, I
should say that one
of the great things you
get on the Google Play
platform or Commerce
platform is that we already
have a lot of buyers.
So somebody's gone along
and added a form of payment,
added their card,
and activated DCB,
become comfortable transacting
in apps on other apps.
And we've got a huge
base of these people.
And then they will become
much easier for you
to convert in your own apps.
So people who have
already made purchases
are correlated with a 40 times--
actually way over 40 times
conversion rate
compared to those who
have not purchased in the past.
This is an extremely
attractive thing
for developers in the platform.
The other thing that
ends up happening
is we keep these buyers active.
Their card expires and
we make sure that they
renew their card.
Or they change carrier
and we get them
on the new carrier billing.
So this is also a very
big deal for developers
such as yourself.
But it's not all about reach.
Reach is fantastic,
but there's also
a lot of optimization and
iteration that goes into this.
I'm going to hand over
to my mate, Mekka,
and he's going to tell you
a little bit more about it.
MEKKA OKEREKE: Thanks Alistair.
So Alistair's right,
reach is fantastic.
So your customers
can buy your products
in over 145 different
countries around the world.
And coverage is great, too.
So coverage is talking
about the different forms
of payment, the different
ways that customers
can buy your products.
But reach and coverage
alone are not enough.
We want to optimize
the purchase experience
so that every one
of your customers
has the best possible purchase
experience wherever they
happen to be around the globe.
So Google Play is a
global commerce platform.
And that's something that I
want you to really internalize.
Most of the customers, most of
the opportunity for purchasing
your apps and your
product is going
to exist outside of the
country that your app is
being developed in.
So I wanted to talk a
little bit about the way
that we think
about optimization.
Now we think about it as
applied effort over time.
We are constantly
improving the platform.
So Google Play obviously is a
very widely distributed app--
over a billion users.
We push out new changes
and improvements
to the purchase flow
every single month.
Now our back-end systems, we
upgrade every single week.
Parts of our back-end system
are upgraded every single day.
The system is always learning,
it's always improving.
What that means for
you as a developer is
that's how we
fulfill the promise.
From last year to this
year our purchase flow
is a little bit faster,
converts a little bit better,
and is a little
bit more available.
And so this is what we do for
the platform on your behalf.
Writing code is fun.
Not writing code and getting
the same result-- also fun.
Deleting code,
that's expert mode.
But, you know, we'll
talk about that later.
So I want to talk
about a little model
that we use to think about
optimizing our purchase flow.
And this works with your
applications as well.
Now we think about commerce,
obviously I love commerce,
but there are other ways to
monetize in your applications
as well.
This works for advertising,
this works for purchases
even outside of commerce.
But this is the model we use.
We think about friction
and motivation.
Now motivation is anything
the gives your users incentive
to make a purchase.
So maybe you have
a great content app
and users want to
subscribe to see
that content, no "Game
of Thrones" spoilers.
And maybe you have
a great game, right.
And you have in-app items that
the user would like to purchase
to advance to the next level.
All of these things
are motivation
that give the user incentive
to make a purchase.
Now friction is
anything that can stop
that purchase from happening.
In fact, friction is also
anything they can even
slow that purchase down.
Now some friction
is really obvious,
if the form of payment
that the user wants to use
is not available, well then
they can't make that purchase.
That's why gift cards
are so important.
A little bit less subtle--
or a little bit more subtle
is things like the number of
clicks or the number of screens
that a user has to go through.
And that would make
sense-- less clicks,
fewer screens
improves conversion.
Now latency and network
connectivity errors.
Again, thinking about a
global commerce platform.
These ones are really important.
Now we're here in
Mountain View, inches
away from Google headquarters.
Our 4G coverage is awesome.
And our Wi-Fi is
unlimited and unmetered.
This is just not the case
for most of your customers
around the globe.
So improvements in
latency and conversion
have a small impact here
in the developed world.
But in countries
like Brazil, India,
Indonesia has a huge
uplift just by making
your applications more resilient
to adverse network situations.
Another even more subtle
one I want to talk about
is cognitive load.
That's a fancy way
of saying how much
do I have to think
before making a purchase.
The answer should be, not much.
So things that interfere
with this, things
that increase cognitive load are
more information on the screen
than is needed to
complete the purchase.
We want to keep the screens
as simple as possible.
Yet we want the customer
to be fully informed
when they make a purchase.
Commerce is a
trust relationship.
You give me money,
I give you stuff.
And if that works out
well, we do this again.
Commerce, to work well, is a
long-term trust relationship.
So you want the user to have
the information to be informed.
But you don't want to
give them more information
than they need.
And the way you solve
that is with good design,
design matters.
So what I mean is for the
UX designers out there,
moving pixels around does
actually drive up revenue.
Now pricing-- pricing is
a huge form of friction
that a lot of people
don't think about.
And this is another
one that I want
you to take very seriously.
And we're going to talk
about this in detail later.
I saw the Android Auto Maserati.
I want a Maserati, who
doesn't want a Maserati.
That price point is
causing me some friction.
[LAUGHTER]
And so having items
priced at the right point
really helps your
users to convert.
And we're going to go
into some examples,
Tamzin is going to
help us with that.
Pricing stuff is hard,
but Tamzin's amazing
so it will all work out.
Localizing the purchase
flow is something that we do
and something that you
can do in your apps.
And it's easy to
say, well I don't
know all the local
markets, I don't know
how to make my app work there.
But some things are
incredibly simple.
So something as simple as in the
United States, we'd like to buy
stuff with credit cards.
In some countries they like to
buy things with bank transfer.
In other countries they like to
buy things on the carrier bill.
So solving the friction point of
enabling customers to purchase,
that problem is solved
in different ways
with different markets.
Now that's looking at
location as one dimension.
But there are many dimensions.
Now everything
we've talked about
so far-- we've talked
about the reach,
we've talked about the coverage.
These are all things
that we're doing.
And it would be great if you
didn't have to do anything,
and everything would just work.
But this is-- the purchase
flow doesn't begin with Google,
the motivation doesn't
begin with Google.
It begins with your
apps and your customers.
And there are some things
that you can really
be optimizing as well.
We're going to go into what
some of those examples are.
And again, this is for
commerce in general.
These are commerce fundamentals.
So I want to talk a little
bit about Rocket Internet.
Rocket Internet is a
global scale company
and they have over
100 applications.
One of their applications
is a food delivery app.
And in this food delivery
app, they analyze their users.
They looked at 60
dimensions, location
being just one of them.
They also looked at
session length, cart size,
what products the
customers were ordering.
They used Google
Analytics to do this.
They loaded it up using
BigQuery and analyzed it.
And what they saw was that
the users kind of broke down
into five clusters.
The top two clusters which
contain just 5% of their users,
drove 40% of their
revenue, right.
So you think Pareto principle.
OK, well then let's
[INAUDIBLE] left.
Let's just throw everyone on
the high-value users and kind
of focus there.
Well not quite, right.
The bottom 95%, again, that
represents your opportunity,
that represents
your growth, that's
where your scale comes from.
So what Rocket did, they
divided their team in half.
Half of the team focused
on high-value users.
And half of the team
focused on the users
who are not yet high-value.
And what they saw
is even looking
at the high-value users, they
saw something interesting.
They saw that these two
cohorts behave differently.
You think your most engaged
users are your highest value
ones, the ones with
the long session times,
and that's not what they saw.
What they saw was that their
most high-value customers had
extremely short session times.
They were getting in,
they knew the app,
they ordered what they
want, and they got out.
Now they had a very high
completion rate of orders,
right.
Hence why the revenue was high.
But they weren't
spending long in the app.
So optimizing for them
means something different.
Optimizing for them means
adding a one-click checkout.
Making that fast
session even faster.
I don't know if they're allowed
to say one-click checkout,
maybe it's less than
two-click checkout.
[LAUGHTER]
But so then they looked
at the other cohort,
the other high-value
user cohort.
And what they saw is
that these users were
doing a lot of repeat ordering.
And again, it was spending
a lot of time in the order
just making the same order
that they made last time.
So optimizing for them
meant putting something,
hey, here's that curry
bowl you ordered last week.
Would you like to
order it again, right.
So this is when you
think about optimizing,
think about optimizing
along many dimensions.
There's lots of different toys.
In this case they used Google
Analytics and BigQuery.
But there's lots of
different ways to do this.
I saw some really amazing
stuff from FireBase,
here at I/O. I don't
know if you guys caught
some of those sessions.
The Play store, we have a
lot of really great tools.
And some of you are building
some really interesting things
that [INAUDIBLE] is doing
some interesting things.
So there's lots of
different ways to do this.
But the key point is
you should be doing it.
And then looking at these users
who are not at the top 95%.
What they saw was that
when they dug into this,
84% of those users were
falling off on the home screen.
They weren't getting any
further than the home screen.
Why?
So they start digging into this.
They started doing
UX experimentation.
They started reducing
the amount of information
you needed to provide
just to get started.
Again, providing too
much data, that's
another form of friction.
I don't want to
fill out a form just
so I can see if your food
delivery app is good, right.
So this is what I
want you all to be
thinking about when you think
about optimizing your app.
Now another example is
optimizing your business model,
how do you monetize.
The simple days used to
be, you got free apps
and then buy my paid app.
That wasn't very great.
Then we're sort of
in today's world
where it's, OK, you've
got the free app
and you've got in-app items
or subscriptions, right.
But maybe you've ad supported.
But I want you to start
thinking about using
these different monetization
mechanisms in combination.
So Lovoo is a dating app.
Is anyone familiar with Lovoo?
Am I saying that right?
Lovoo.
[LAUGHTER]
I always wonder if
I'm saying it right.
And so there's really two
different types of dating apps.
There is one's that are
really trying to develop
long-term connections.
And those tend to be
subscription-type apps.
And then there are ones
that are much more casual.
Swipe left, swipe right--
that kind of thing.
And those tend to use
in-app billing items.
So you can buy super likes or a
oh dear God, what have I done,
no, no, no button.
You know, this type of thing.
What Lovoo noticed was that
they could combine these two
things to get a good result.
Because the casual daters were
very unlikely to subscribe.
So what they did was they
said, well let's offer both.
Let's offer
subscription for people
looking for a
long-term connection.
And let's offer in-app
items for people
looking for casual dating.
And that worked, they were able
to monetize these customers
that they weren't able
to monetize before.
But something amazing happened.
They noticed that over time
the casual daters, 10% of them
subscribed and became higher RPU
long-term connection customers.
This gives me hope.
People, a lot of people really
do want long-term connection
with other human beings.
It's not all about
just hooking up, right.
So this is interesting.
Think about the
different models that you
can use to monetize your app.
Now we have a promotions
team on Google Play that
builds promotions for customers,
things like discount codes,
coupons, that kind of thing.
The mission of that team is the
right offer for the right user
in the right context at scale.
Now Underwater apps, I don't
know what's going on here,
but they get that
mission crystal clear.
They have implemented
this in their own app.
So what they do-- again,
they combine advertising
and in-app purchase items.
But what they do is
they used the player
stats API to understand the
behavior of their users.
Which users are they going to
monetize through advertising,
which users are they
going to monetize
through in-app purchasing.
Again, in the old
days it used to be--
get my free version it has
ads, get my paid version
and-- or upgrade to
freemium it has no ads.
But why make the user have to
make that conscious choice.
Why raise the cognitive load,
how do you bring that down.
We bring it down by
analyzing the data
and making that
understand-- getting
that understanding
without the user having
to tell you anything.
So they were able
to predict which
users were likely to spend.
Now what do they
do with this data?
The users that were
likely to spend,
they decided not to
show those users ads.
And what they saw was that
revenue went up by 15%.
Don't show ads to the customers
who are about to spend.
And again, you don't have
to ask the users for this,
you can understand this
from looking at the data.
They also did something else.
For the users that were unlikely
to ever spend in the app,
normally for an in-app purchase
type app that might be a wash.
What they decided was to
up the frequency of the ads
so that when the users open the
ad, everything-- open the app,
every time they saw one ad.
Before it was something
less than one.
What they were able
to see was they
were able to increase
the advertising revenue
from those users by 17%.
That's pretty awesome.
And again, the user doesn't
have to do anything.
This is understanding your
data, understanding your users
deeply, and segmenting.
So we've talked a lot
about the different types
of optimization.
We've talked about
reach and coverage.
But pricing optimization
is its own topic.
I think it's deserving
of its own section.
So Tamzin is going
to help us with that.
Thank you.
TAMZIN TAYLOR: Thanks, Mekka.
So Mekka and Alistair
have just taken us
through all of the
things which we
are doing to work so hard
to make our Play Commerce
platform make more
money for you.
So what I'm going
to talk about is
I'm going to give you some
examples of developers
who have really taken
advantage of the platforms
that we offer to
make more money.
In the next 10
minutes or so, I'll
take you through some
examples of developers
who use creativity,
they've used localization,
and more importantly
used experimentation
to increase revenue
and conversion.
So Scopely is a fantastic
American games application.
I know there's someone
in the audience today,
so if you have any questions
you can hunt her down.
Scopely has over 50 million
downloads worldwide.
And they are a role-playing
and strategy game.
Their recent games you
can see in the screen
is "The Walking Dead".
Now traditionally, RPG and
strategy games-- and I'm
sure I don't need
to tell you this,
I'm sure you people
know-- monetize
through e-net purchasing.
But Scopely had a challenge.
How can they increase
retention and new users.
So why is this
important for Scopely?
Well when you think about
an RPG strategy game,
it's really important to build
an ecosystem of players, right.
So that you can create
a team and battle it out
against each other.
Who here plays RPG games?
I would expect it
from you Philip.
Good, yes.
Excellent.
So how do they approach
this challenge?
Well, because they are great
users of the Google Play
platform, they came up with
an innovative monetization
technique.
They introduced a 30-day pass.
OK, so the really great
thing about this pass
was when you downloaded
it, when you bought it,
you got an instant 270 coins.
OK, so what.
But then, here is the kicker.
Every time you came back into
the game, on a daily basis,
within that 30-day period you
got an additional 70 coins.
So in effect, what they're
doing is incentivizing users
to come back and play the
game and grow that ecosystem.
So they combined subscription
with in-app purchases
to really grow retention.
But that's not all,
what they found,
which was really
surprising to them,
was that their new users and
non-paying users increased.
What they saw was that
1/3 of all their purchases
of this pack were
brand new users.
And 2/3 of those were
non-payers-- long-term
non-payers.
Now did anyone see
Mateo's talk on Wednesday?
OK, Philip again, good.
So I'd encourage you to have
a look at that Livestream
when you go back home.
But he goes into more
detail about using data
to really understand
your audience.
But in game language, what
I've been told by Scopely,
is that if a user doesn't
actually spend money
in between the first
one and seven days,
or really one in three, they're
highly unlikely to ever spend
any money.
Now the name of the
game here, I think
the presentation's called "How
to Make money on Google Play",
so Scopely is a great example
because what they have
effectively done is unlock
these long-term non-paying base
of users to create
a whole new market.
Now unlocking new users
and long-term non-spenders
is important for everyone.
Wouldn't you agree?
Yeah, everyone wants
more money, more payers.
And its normal- its most
important in emerging markets.
Who here is from
an emerging market?
A few people, excellent.
Yeah, I'm from an emerging
market as well, I'm Australian.
OK.
So it is emerging.
[LAUGHTER]
Just no one knows about it yet.
So Divmob is an example
of one of our partners
who really took advantage of our
new lower minimum price floors
that we launched
earlier this year.
Now as I mentioned and
Mekka mentioned and Alistair
mentioned, we're working
really, really hard
to increase more forms of
payment in more countries
so that people can buy from you.
We think it's really important,
because we want to unlock
all these great users for you.
So Divmob is a great company,
they're based in Vietnam.
So no one knows
more than they do,
how people in emerging markets
have different abilities
to pay.
And they're a huge company.
They've recently,
I think they've
had about 40 million
downloads, and they've just
launched their game
"Epic Heroes War",
which just got nominated Top
Developer and Editor's Choice.
So with all this success,
you think fantastic,
they're doing so well.
Well in fact, what
they saw was that they
had all these users
in emerging markets,
they just weren't buying,
they weren't paying.
And if you think
about it, before we
made the change on the
minimum price floor,
it was $0.99 American.
Now if anyone is from Vietnam
here, $0.99 I checked it today
is 22,000 dong, that's
the Vietnamese currency.
Now for 22,000 dong, you can
get a really, really tasty lunch
in Vietnam.
How much would your
lunch cost you today
if you had to pay for it?
$8.
$10.
Is that, does that
sound like something
you'd pay as a minimum
price to play a game?
So put it in that context.
Now Divmob were
desperate to start
testing because they had
the data that backed up
their hypothesis, that once
you've got someone just buying
something, just
paying something,
you could actually
grow them, grow
their RPU through cross-selling,
upgrading the game,
and doing more of
these kinds of things.
So as soon as we
changed the system
and allowed them to
price lower than $0.99.
They start experimenting
Vietnam, Thailand, Malaysia
Philippines and the
results were outstanding.
They created an introductory
pass at the minimum floor,
and they saw a 300% increase
in paid transactions.
300% increase.
And best yet, they saw that
their base of paying users
tripled.
And that was after
the blip of promotion.
So we're talking about
consistent result. Furthermore,
who are all these new users
who are pretty happy to now
be able to get
into the game, they
saw a 17% increase in retention.
So retention, monetization,
all goes together.
And the best part is
that if you fast forward
a couple of months, six out
of 10 of their top transaction
markets by volume
of transactions
are now these sub-dollar
price countries.
So what this has
done is really open
up a huge new
market for them, one
which weren't paying before.
Now another fantastic
company, we love very much
and is in the audience
today, is Animoca.
So Animoca also
were very, very keen
to test sub-dollar pricing
because they again,
they also knew they had all
these customers in emerging
markets who weren't paying, and
this is a fantastic opportunity
to try and move them
along the RPU ladder.
Now Divmob had over 400 apps
live and over 430 million
downloads to date.
So they know something
about testing and pricing.
Divmob took a different
approach-- sorry,
Animoca took a
different approach
and created sachet pricing.
Now with these sachet
prices you could
get 100 diamonds and 5,000 coins
for the lowest minimum price
in that country.
And the way they structured
it was quite interesting.
This wasn't a regular price.
It wasn't a regular SKU.
It was actually a
promotional SKU that
was targeted to these users.
And the way they promoted it
was through native banners
inside the app.
So native billboards
and posters.
And they were very
happy with the results.
They saw that 90% of all
buyers of the sachet prices
were absolutely new buyers.
And better yet, as
you can confirm,
50% of all of those buyers went
on to become repeat purchasers.
And let me be clear, they
weren't repeatedly buying
the cheap option,
they were repeatedly
buying the full priced items.
So you can see that
what's happening here
is you're getting new
payers in and you're just
taking them on the RPU journey
to increase their value.
So this really has opened up new
markets, increased retention,
and increased revenue
to these partners.
Now using minimum
prices can really
help in emerging markets.
But obviously, you've also got
a mature markets to target,
right.
So SGN is one example
of a games company
you might be familiar with.
They have over 700 million
downloads across the world.
And they're responsible
for the franchises Juice
Jam, Cookie Jam, and Panda Pop.
They really thought that
localizing pricing could really
have a big impact
in some markets.
So they took their top
markets and they used
the economists Big Mac Index.
And then they
rounded those prices
to the user's preferred
country price format.
Now let me break that down.
So who here knows about
the Big Mac Index?
Cool.
OK, for those of you who
may be less familiar,
the Big Mac Index is basically
a-- it's a bit of analysis that
The Economist newspaper
has done, where--
Thank you very much.
And what it does is it shows
you the comparative price
to the McDonald's hamburger
from America to say Vietnam.
So you can really get a sense
of-- because Mc is you know,
they're pretty smart
about these things.
You can get a sense of
what the prices should
be in that market.
Now when we talk about
price formats, what
we mean is that in some
markets like Korea and Japan,
they prefer whole
rounded numbers.
So instead of 653
yen, they prefer 700.
So rounded figures.
Now they tested in-- as
I said, their top markets
and what they saw was
quite interesting.
They saw that in some markets
like Italy and Switzerland.
RPU increased as much as 78%.
In other markets they saw
a neutral revenue impact
such as Korea and Norway.
But above all, across all of
the countries they tested in,
they saw a 30% increase in ARPU.
They were really
happy with this,
because they kept wanting
to do more testing.
And as a result they've
rolled these prices out
to all of their apps and games.
Now the lesson here is that
a 10% increase or decrease
in a certain country is not
going to work for everyone.
The lesson here is
that we want you
to test your prices in
these different markets,
and see what works for your
customers in those markets.
OK, so we've talked
about, we've talked
about games a lot haven't we.
Talked about Scopely,
Divmob, Animoca, SGN.
But it's not just
the games companies
who are leading the
innovation in pricing.
One example of a great
app company is Memrise.
Memrise are a leading
language learning application.
The nature of their
content, obviously,
learning lots of languages
is that their a global app.
And they have a very
large proportion of users
from emerging markets.
Now they're a young company.
So they only actually launched
price propositions back
in July 2015.
They just launched
monthly and annual passes.
So in August they decided
they'd try localizing prices.
They used the BMI, the
Big Mac Index again,
and they saw reductions between
10% and 80% on their prices
depending on the country.
What they found was
a really good impacts
in countries like Egypt, India,
Mexico, Ukraine, Saudi Arabia.
Above all they saw 46%
in new subscribers.
Now we've talked a
little about localizing
prices, which is great.
But to back all this up,
what's really important
is to have an
experimentation mindset.
So I'm going to take you through
a couple examples of partners
who do this extremely well.
They've really
thought long and hard
about the way they present
the price, what the price is,
and then how it's formatted.
Because the key here is
about-- has anyone heard
about psychological pricing.
OK.
So basically, if anyone's been
to a restaurant on a date,
you don't choose
the cheapest wine,
you choose the
second cheapest wine.
[LAUGHTER]
Shh, don't tell anyone.
And so this is the
idea, that you want
to create this idea of value.
You want to create a reference
point in the user's mind.
So they go, well I could
get that lower priced one,
and there's that expensive
one, but that one in the middle
looks really good.
And so this is the kind of
thing we're talking about here.
Now Peak is an excellent app.
They are global leaders
in brain training.
And they know that they need
to really listen to their users
to continue to test and
iterate to stay ahead
of the competition.
So what they did was they
tested two different value
propositions to
see how they would
impact conversion and revenue.
The first they tested
was how can they--
similar to the ones we
talked about earlier,
how can they actually get
non-payers to start paying.
In this instance they ran
an A/B test where they said,
what would happen if when
the user gets to the point
where they hit subscribe,
instead they go uh,
and they back out
and they cancel.
So what Peak did was
present them a screen that
said, oh, before you go we'll
give you a 20% discount if you
subscribe today.
This actually resulted in a 25%
increase in those people who
saw the screen subscribing.
So never say never.
The second thing they tested
was how to increase RPU.
As I mentioned, or
maybe I didn't mention,
they had a monthly and
annual subscription.
Well they wanted to test
was a lifetime subscription.
So you know what I just said
about creating a reference
point in people's mind--
in that sense of value.
The lifetime subscription
was three times
the price of the
annual subscription.
But if you think about
the kind of content
it is, people have an
altruistic view that they're
going to really
improve their brain,
they're going to smash it out.
Well they found was that
10% now of all subscribers,
are lifetime subscribers.
And here's the kicker.
I'm sure for you
as app developers,
cash flow is really important.
Having this lifetime
subscription
has increased the return on
acquisition cost by 30%--
it's coming in at 30% faster,
because you're getting
more cash flow in quicker.
So consider things like
this when you're pricing.
Memrise have also done
some interesting stuff
around psychological pricing.
If anyone knows we
actually launched
quarterly subscriptions
in September last year.
Yeah!
I was very excited.
So Memrise already had monthly
and annual subscriptions.
And they were very
keen to test quarterly.
Again, learning a language
is an altruistic-- I really
want to do it, it's a
self-fulfilling enjoyable task.
So what they found was
that-- well first of all,
they were a bit
concerned that people
would stop buying it annual
and move to the quarterly.
But what they found was
that actually the people
who were usually
buying the monthly
started buying the quarterly.
And there was no
cannibalization of the annual.
And this resulted in
a 72% lift in RPU.
Plus they saw 33% more users.
They also tested
point-in-time messaging.
So you know I talked
about when Peak
had that back out flow message.
Memrise did a similar thing.
But instead of
targeting non-payers,
Memrise was seeing if
they could increase
RPU of existing subscribers.
So they targeted monthly
and quarterly users,
or subscribers.
And we ended up having a really
good learning experience.
When they were really
smashing it out, winning
all their tests, Memrise would
give them a call to action,
hey, you're doing so well.
Why don't you just
upgrade to the annual pass
and save some money.
And this resulted in a doubling
of RPU for those users.
So Peak and Memrise are
two really good examples
of developers who have
really, really employed
price experimentation to
grow revenue and conversion.
Now the final example
I'll talk about
is interesting because it's
not about the price itself,
and it's not about
reference pricing.
It's about how do you
describe the value
that you're offering users for
the cash you're asking for.
Now has anyone used Runtastic?
Good.
OK.
So Runtastic has 17 apps
live in the app store.
If you know, they started
out as a premium offering.
And about a year
and a half ago, they
moved to subscription model.
So conversion's really
important for them.
Now what they saw
from their data
was that people were dropping
off on that final screen,
on the final purchase screen.
And they had a suspicion that
maybe if they changed the way
they presented the copy,
that would have an impact.
So the original screen
had all the features
listed out in great detail.
So what they tested was having
just the one key feature
called out in a
cleaner simpler screen.
This resulted in a 103%
lift in conversion.
So you can see that testing
different price propositions,
representations,
and descriptions
can really increase
conversion and revenue.
So today we've
covered quite a bit.
We've talked about
how our goal in life
is to make sure that
every single Android
user in the world can buy
your content no matter
where they are and what
format they want to pay in.
We've talked about how we want
to remove all the friction
from the payment flow.
And we've given
you some examples
of developers who've
used creativity
and leveraged our platform
in different ways to increase
revenue.
Now one thing I'm
going to call out,
I know we mentioned
analytics before,
but all of the
developers we talked
about today use
experimentation and data
to drive their product pricing
and proposition decisions.
And they all think
about how much
can the users in different
countries that I serve afford.
Now, the Big Mac Index is free.
You can go and have
a look at it today.
It's no problem.
So I really encourage you
to consider these things
we've talked about today.
And apply them to
your own app because I
can speak on behalf
of these guys,
we're so excited to see
what you'll do next.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]